对，
我大概是有几个问题，
第一个问题就是我妈妈她一直都没有抚养我的吧，
我爸爸妈妈离婚的，
后面的话，
她问我要抚养费的话，
我是需要给的吗？
拿那个赡养费是吧？
赡养费得有一个前提，
就是说你的妈妈她现在生活的怎么样，
她有没有退休金，
她自己有没有经济来源，
她自己有没有劳动能力，
如果说她自己有劳动的能力，
有经济来源，
从法律上来说的话，
她是没有资格问你要这个赡养费的，
如果有一天他确实是没有经济来源，
没有劳动能力，
活不下去了，
没有办法吃饱饭的这样一个生活水平了，
他问你要赡养费，
那么你就让他去告你，
告你了之后法院判，
判多少给多少，
判800给800，
让1000给1000。
还有一个问题啊，
就是我家里面是比较重男轻女的嘛，
我现在面临的一个问题就是我想在婚前买房，
然后的话还有一个问题，
就是我妹妹的话，
今年高三，
她目前的成绩不是他要上大学的话，
他基本上就是二本，
如果我买了房，
我就没有钱给他读大学，
就是在里面我是应该先买房还是留下钱给他读大学了，
这个事儿啊，
我觉得取决于你和妹妹之间的这个缘分感情，
因为就算是亲的兄弟姊妹之间也有缘分深的，
也有缘分浅的，
如果你和你的妹妹从小感情很好，
你对他有这个感情，
他跟你有这个缘分，
我觉得。
假设你的爸爸妈妈不管他重男轻女，
如果你不出这个钱，
你的爸爸妈妈不可能出这个钱，
那他的人生可能会有一个很大的这样一个改变，
如果你给他出这个钱，
他的人生可能境遇大不相同，
在这种前提条件下，
也是可以资助妹妹上大学的，
房子的事情晚点买也是可以的，
但如果说你俩感情也不咋地是吧，
你也没有这个缘分，
你妹妹也从小也没那么粘你，
没那么喜欢你，
这事儿的话，
人各有命，
那我二年动了，
就是还有个问题，
现在目前的话，
我跟我男朋友面临就是一个呃，
准备要结婚的一个状态嘛，
我的话，
他那边的彩礼，
因为我是在广东这边的，
他那边呢，
说是给我九万九吧，
呃，
就是我那个彩礼的话，
我手头上的钱，
然后再加上彩礼的钱，
我就大概有30来万的样子吧，
那这30来万这笔钱我需要怎么样，
就是给我自己留一个最大的保证呢？
因为如果一旦我结婚了以后，
我可能就跟呃，
我的父母的人份，
你可能就不要钱，
你借30多万的话，
你在领取结婚证之前，
你单独去开一张银行卡，
这张卡不干别的，
不要绑定你的消费，
不要绑定你的微信，
不要绑定你的支付宝，
他只来干一件事情，
就是把你婚前的所有存款都存到这张卡里面去，
存定期也好，
或者换成一个大额的存单也好，
那么这个钱就是你的婚前个人财产，
就算有一天你俩感情不。
好了，
要分开的话，
也分不着这笔钱，
我现在就是还有个疑问，
就是以我的性格的话，
如果你旦我这个钱如果是存在银行，
我是分分钟有可能拿出来的，
因为我就感觉我的性格就是比较软一点的，
存大额保单，
大额的定期存款啊，
但是大额的定期存款也能取出来，
就是我很害怕，
就是一旦就是我跟他结婚以后，
男的一年以后就说哎呀我要投资啊什么之类的，
我这三四十万我可能就是打水漂了，
你怕自己心软是不是，
对对对，
因为前面我也提到说说，
因为我知道我的性格，
我跟我妹妹的感情是比较好的，
因为我也是因为没有钱，
因为我也是当时因为父母的一个情况，
然后我就没有多大学，
所以我一方面是不想我妹妹错过了这个机会，
但是我能力也有限，
所以我现在的问题就是我现在我这笔钱我是存在而不化，
我要怎样让自己认就其是不管发生什么事情，
我都不能把这笔钱拿下来，
就是有什么意愿能让自己坚强把这笔钱存下来，
就是我想把我的婚钱保存啊，
但是除了买房是不是没有别的更好的方法，
因为我不想存银啊，
我觉得存银我是保证我会拿出来的，
你还有一个方案，
你去咨询一下银行那个金条政策，
可以直接换成金条存银行，
换成你刚刚说的那个是吗？
对你当然这个事情哦，
龙飞姐，
我觉得首先你自己要去多学习一下。
学习一下，
多了解一下这个事情，
看看这个会不会保值和增值，
在你学习了解了之后再做这个决定，
因为如果说只是存在你的银行卡上的数字，
那你想转出来你就转出来了，
对不对？
但如果存的是金条，
那不一样啊，
哦，
那我大概懂了，
我本来是想选择在婚前买房的，
好像我买房也不知道干嘛，
主要是你男朋友这边有房吗？
他有，
对，
那你买房干啥呢？
就是说你买房也不一定保值增值对不对，
而且有可能把自己拖累进去，
对不对，
是的，
所以我就想他怎么样，
有一个就是后退的路，
有几种选择吧，
第一种选择就是我刚刚跟你讲的，
换成金条存在银行。
第二种选择你去了解一下，
给自己买，
比如年金险这样的保险产品，
都去了解一下啊，
那我走，
还有就是你妹妹那个事情啊，
你妹妹那个事情，
首先去了解助学贷款政策，
助学贷款这方面的政策的话，
因因为我自己当年啊，
我是05年读的大学，
我那个时候就是国家给我的助学贷款，
一年给5000块钱，
然后四年是2万块钱，
这样的话，
他基本上学费也等于能覆盖了，
那么你对你妹妹的话，
就是覆盖一下他的生活费了，
这样的话又要轻松很多，
等他自己毕业了之后，
自己可以挣钱去还那个助学贷款，
那我的其实我的想法就是很简单，
我要把钱花出去，
别人才拿不掉，
这样子对我来说才是有一条后路，
你知道吧，
那我已经想好，
如果要结婚生孩子，
哪怕是说以后。
就跟这个男的分开了，
我这个小孩我一定是要带在我自己的身边，
我一定要给自己找一条后路，
你可以多了解，
还有一个险种叫做增额终身寿险，
增额终身寿险他约等于是存钱的意思，
一定要找大保险公司，
哦哦，
就这里给我方法，
因为目前我是不太考虑买房，
买金条的话，
我要看现在金价位太贵了，
因为钱就这么多，
那好，
那谢谢同飞姐姐，
我刚刚看到很多人都说，
哎呀，
先顾好自己，
不要顾妹妹，
有的时候大恩如大仇，
这事儿吧，
分人就是说他们两姊妹之间的话，
如果妹妹能够体谅姐姐的不容易，
能够体谅姐姐对他的这一份付出，
那也是给自己多一个亲人嘛，
对不对，
在妹妹最需要的时候，
最需要改变人生的方向，
人生的阶梯的时候，
如果姐姐能扶她一把，
那是可能是另一番景象，
所以这事儿龙飞姐从一开始就问了，
说你们姐妹俩的感情深不深，
缘分深不深？
这事儿就是人和人不一样，
有的兄弟姊妹之间他就是最亲的人是吧，
兄弟姊妹之间是属于那种相互之间扶持，
一直走到老的人，
有的兄弟姊妹之间就是属于世界上相互最仇视的两个人，
可能他对别人没有那么大的深仇大恨，
对自己的兄弟姐妹深仇大恨，
嫉妒心、
怨恨特别深。
这事儿就是分人，
我不知道直播间姐妹们同不同意，
而且兄弟姐妹和兄弟姐妹之间还不一样。
他是一个妈生的，
或者两个妈生的，
就像历史上你们都知道啊，
雍正和十三爷他俩不是一个妈生的，
十三爷的地位相当于朝父皇帝这么一个地位，
对吧？
就是得罪雍正的人或许还能活命，
为什么有十三爷去帮忙求情，
但是得罪十三爷，
欺负十三爷的人肯定是活不了的，
就他俩关系能到那个程度，
但是十三爷有自己一个亲弟弟，
一奶同胞的亲弟弟，
十四爷他俩就是跟乌鸡眼似的逗的啊，
就相互都看不上眼，
相互之间怨恨可大了。
所以这事儿我跟你说，
就是拼缘分，
如果说兄弟姊妹之间有这样的缘分，
在他们弱小的时候，
需要的时候扶一把，
能扶一把还是得扶一把。